ونحييكم من جديد اعاده وثائقيون خاص
للعربيه بعنوان محاكم التفكير حول المفكر
العربي نص الحامد ابو زيد تتبع خطوط حمله
التكفير الشرسه التي شريتها جمعته الاسلام
السياسي ضد شخص نصر حامد ابو زيد وكيف
اراد البعض تفريقه عن زوجته تحت دعوه
قانون الحسبه ومحاوله الاخرين هدر دمه
ليجد نفسه مضطر لمغادره وطنه لوصله من
غربته تصدي لهجوم المتطرفين واستئناف
المعركه القضائيه
اساتذه شاركوا كتاب واساتذه شاركوا في
الوثائقي واوضح ان كتاب ابو زيد مفهومه
الدارسين اللغه والادب والدراسات
الاسلاميه بشكل كبير كما كشف الوثائقي
انطلاع خلافات كثيره
وسجلات داخل مصر بسبب كتاب ابو زيد نقد
الخطاب الديني الذي انتقد فيه الخطاب
الدينيه الذي كان يستخدمه كمالي شركه
تنظيف الاموال لاستقاب بسه كتبه كانت
متاحه وكانت مقروءه وما كانش في اي حملات
ضده ايه السبب اللي ولع الدنيا
مش في افكار واجتهادات لا اللي ولع الدنيا
كتاب صغير قد كده اسمه نقد الخطاب الديني
هذا الكتاب كان في مناح عام في مصر في ذلك
الوقت كانت شركات توظيف الاموال اللي تسمى
اسلاميه انتقد
باسلوب علمي همم
الخطاب الديني اللي كان همم في ذلك الوقت
مناصر او بيستخدم ليه همم الدعايه لشركه
توظيف الاموال
[موسيقى]
في سبعينات وثمانينات القرن الماضي دعت
شركات توظيف الاموال المصريين الى ايداع
اموالهم لديها لاستثمارها كبديل عن البنوك
بالزعمي انهم قادرون على تقديم ارباح اعلى
وان فوائد البنوك نوع من الربا
من بين شركات توظيف الاموال كانت شركه
الريان والسعد هما الاشهر
وانتهى الحال بتلك الشركات الى الحل
وملاحقه اصحابها قضائيا لعجزهم عن سداد
اموال المذيعين
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا هنا في
الاستوديو فهد الشقيران الباحث الصحفي
السعودي اهلا بك استاذ فهد معنا من
القاهره فريده شوبيشي الكاتبه صحفيه وعضو
البرلمان المصري اهلا بكم ضيفايا واسمحالي
ان ابدا هنا في الاستوديو معك يا سيد فهد
سيد فهد لماذا احدث هذا الوثائقي واعظم
جديد هو في الواقع ضجه حول من انقسم
الشارع على تسميته بين المفكر التنويري
واخرون وصفوا بالملحد همم لماذا هذه الضجه
نزلت موجوده وعبر عقود نصر حامد ابو زيد
هو ظاهره وعلامه الفقيه وشيخ وفيلسوف جمع
بين كل هذه الصفات وظاهره وهو فريد في
منهاج الذي ذكرني ذلك همم الفلاسفه الكبار
الذين مروا على تاريخ البشريه من الايطالي
والباخ الى
ادرنه وغيرهم من الفلاسفه وقال لي
كوبرنيكوس كلهم كفروا او قتلوا او قطعت
السنتهم في طبيعه الامور بالنسبه
للمجتماعات المتخلفه التي لم تدخل عصر
الانوار من بينهم الكتابه الذي غير وجه
البشريه مقاله في المنهج الليرينيه ديكارت
في القرن السادس عشر والذي طورد ايضا على
هذا الكتاب لانه طرح منهجا جديدا في البحث
عن الحقيقه كذلك نصر ابو زيد نصر ابو زيد
طرح منهج مختلف في البحث عن همم في بحث
الذكر بحوث الدراسات
حساسه لم يقترب من نقاط حساسه وانما طرح
طرحا عقلانيه من داخل الدائره الدينيه
الاسلاميه وبادوات الشريعه الاسلاميه
المحكمه وهو بدا في حياته شيخا صغيرا عالم
في الدنيا يعني درس سواء استفاده من
العلوم الشرعيه الكثير همم لم يقترب من
نقاط قويه وانما طرح مثل الاطروحه عن
المعتزله مثلا اول كتاب له روحته حول
التفسير العقلي عند المعتزله وتحدث عن غير
المجاز طبعا هذا البحث موجود من زمان يعني
بنتهي من بحث في المجاز وعطل المجاز ليس
تعطيلا ع- همم تعطيل اللغوي المجالس موجود
في اللغه وانما عطله من اجل ان يقطع
الطريق على الذين ياولون في الاسماء
والصفات لكن ناصر ابو زيد نقطه قوه نصر
حامد ابو زيد انه عالم في الشريعه وعالم
في العلوم الانسانيه
فريده يقول بان همم الضجه التي حصلت هي
اختلافات بين اصدقاء في الواقع حتى
القريبين من نصر حمد ابو صديق كلهم بانه
في بدايته كان معجب همم بالاخوان المسلمين
او بنظام همم الاخوان وكان يقرا لهم حتى
همم فكيف اندلعت بحسب رايك هذه هي الضجه
من وقتها هل لانه اقترب من ملفات حساسه او
لامور شخصيه بين بعض الافراد
هو الحقيقه
الاستاذ نصر حامد ابو زيد كان راجل مستنير
وبيدعوا الى الاستماره والى اليقظه لانه
احنا وقعنا في الفتره الاخيره
يعني فريسه لكل المتاجرين بالدين واللي
شفنا مثلا زي الريان والتاني ده بتوع
وظائف الاموال توظيف الاموال
هيستقبلوا كلام ناصر حامد ابو زيد ببساطه
كده لا طبعا لازم يقومه كل الابواق
بتاعتهم لانه ما فيش احد اخذ حقه والبنوك
على الاقل يعني كان اللي بيحط فيها فلوس
ما يحصلش همم يعني فوائد او يحصل اي حاجه
كان بيروح ياخذ فلوسه لكن دول هم اللي
مشوا صابونه فانا عايز افهم يعني ايه
حكايه التكفير انا فوجئت على فكره انا عشت
بره حوالي 30 سنه من اوائل السبعينات
لغايه
رجعت في اواخر التسعينات واتفزعت من من
تغيير اللي حصل في الشارع يعني الشارع كل
حاجه ده كافر انت ما لك حتى ربنا رب العزه
والجلال قال ايه فمن جاء فليمن ومن شاء
فليكفر يعني انت عايز تعدل على ربنا
سبحانه وتعالى استغفر الله العظيم يعني
فمثل حامل ده ابو زيد كانت دعوه للتفكير
اللي احنا نشغل مخنا ما ناخذش كلام بعض
يعني حسب رايه هو بدليل انه في اكثر من
همم مذهب مثلا في ال- في الاسلام يعني لو
كان ممنوع الكلام وممنوع التفكير وممنوع
البحث كان ما فيش احد يقدر ربنا قال اقرا
نعم اخرس هم بيقولوا اخرس يعني ما فيش
كلام احنا اللي نقوله بس لا ما فيش احد
يكون عنده كرامه
تتحدثين
بالدين كما يصفهم لبعض وهنا سؤالي همم
الحذرتك سيد همم فهد همم هل يمكن اعتبار
همم نصر حامد ابو زيد اضحيه للمتجرم
بالدين وكيف
فتره احنا نتذكر ايات شيطانيه لسلمان رشدي
صدرت في 88
وايه جاء نصر ابو زيد في اوائل التسعينات
وبدا يطرح كتبه الغريب انه هذه
يتاجرون بالدين ووقع عليهم قبض عليهم من
اصل حامد ابو زيد بكتابه نقل الخطاب
الديني مع اني اعتبره من اخذ كتبه يعني لم
يكن ذاك الكتاب العميق اللي كتبها بعد 95
او اللي همم
وهو وهو الذي شكل خطوره بالنسبه لانه كان
الكتاب كان صيحه صيحه في الصحراء انه
انتبهوا من هؤلاء
النصابين الغشاشين الذين يتاجرون بالدين
ووقع عليهم وكانت الحكومه انا ذاك النظام
المصري كان قد عقد صفقه بغض النظر عنهم
وانا اتمنى ان يكون هناك ايضا حمايه لناصر
محمد ابو زيد على غرار الحمايه التي
حصل عليها حينما هاجر الى هولندا وانا
في في اخر مراسله بيني وبينهم هل له نشاط
شديد قال قال لي انه ذاهب الى امريكا ثم
مدريد ثم اسطنبول ثم اندونيسيا لما ذهب
الى اندونيسيا لقط الفيروس لقط فيروس غريب
فماتها في مصر
فمامات صغيره لو انا اتوقع لو عاش نصر
حامد ابو زيد همم سنوات
ليس هذا
اقصى ما لدى النصر حامد ابو زيد من يعرف
نصر حامد ابو زيد يعرف ان هذا ليس هذا
اقسام
كل هذه النقاشات الا ان موضوع التطرف
والتكفير الذي نددت به منذ قليل الا زال
موجود
اين المشكله
غير مشكله في
المناخ اللي ساد منذ منتصف السبعينات انه
انا اتكلم وانت تخرس ما انا باقول لك يعني
ربنا قال اقرا هم قالوا اخرس اي حد يفكر
ممنوع التفكير وده على فكره اللي مخلينا
يعني انت عارفه انا من كم يوم كده كنت
افكر مثلا عندما يقولون ان كل شيء حصل في
الانسانيه ذكر في القران طب انت لست انت
مسؤولا بعدم تنفيذ بجائب القران وانتظرت
حتى يعني نفذه الاخرون يعني احنا ما فيش
حاجه مش واخديننا من الغرب كل حاجه احنا
واخذينها من الغرب اي حاجه تقدم يعني
سياره تليفون موبايل كمبيوتر اي حاجه هي
الفكره انه بقى فيه جو قمعي مرعب باسم
الدين مع ان الدين مش كده خالص يعني انت
بتتحاكمني انا انا يعني مع انه ربنا
يحاكمني اه ويبقى الدين مش مظهر مش يعني
انت تلاقيني مثلا همم لابسه لبس معين
باتصرف بطريقه معينه همم باقول كلام معين
يبقى انا خلاص بقى لا ما حدش يقدر يعرف
ربنا وحده يعلم خائنه الاعين وما تخفي
الصدور فين ده على فكره دول بعدوا عن
الدين خالص يعني ناصر حامد ابو زيد كان
راجل فعلا مسلم ومؤمن ومؤمن همم يعني همم
عظمه الدين الاسلامي في تحيه الفرصه
للتفكير يعني وقتاحه الفرصه للعمل ما حدش
فيهم ابدا قال كل الاعماله فسيرى الله
عملكم ورسوله والمؤمنون كله لا همم اعمل
اللي انا عايزه لا مش كده وبعدين نقلونا
الى همم تشويه الاسلام يعني الاسلام انت
لما تلاقي واحد مش عاجبك كثير وبعدين تصلي
ركعتين خلاص
صحيح ولكن وانا صغيره
استاذ فهد يعني اليوم هنا كتابات لكن هنا
كذلك وثائقيات كل التي تتابعناها همم ما
الا لي الاجده التي يجب اتباعها هناك ذلك
دراسيا مثلا للتصدي لهذه الطيارات
انا تمنيت من ناصر حمد ابو زيد ان لا يكتب
رساله اللي كانت نشرها في روز اليوسف اللي
كان فيها نوع من نوع كانهن صاع قليلا
لطالبات بعض المتشددين نتمنيت انه اذا
هاجموه هجوما واحدا ان يكتب عنهم كتابتين
اذا هاجمه مر اذا هاجموه مرتين ان يكتب
عنهم اربعه كتب هذه الطريقه الناجحه
للهجوم على الاسلام لان هم يخرسون حينما
تهاجمهم بقوه بشده يخرسون ليست لديه من
قوه الطاعه لانهم يخافون ايضا ان ينتشر
فكرك بشكل اكبر يعني عنك وانا هنا في
الحقيقه القوه التي تتمتع بها النصر ابو
زيد اشكر زوجته ابتهال يونس يعني انا
اعترف انه في لا انا مؤمن انه لولا وجود
زوجته لكان ضعف لانه رجل عاطفي والانسان
يضرب
طب اقوى منها هي قويه وذهبت معها وسافرت
نطرحه الى النقاش شكرا جزيلا لك فاشقيرا
الكاتب الصحفي السعودي وشكر كذلك الاستاذه
فريده شوبشي الكاتبه الصحفي السلام عليكم